another friend of yours or maybe former
friend of yours looks like he's going to
run again Donald Donald yeah big Donald
sure he's running here what what do you
think about that is that going to be a
good thing for America I'm hearing the
same stuff I heard in 2015. but he
hasn't got a cat and hell's chance of
winning absolutely he's got a chance of
winning he wins a republican nomination
that's probably going to be the toughest
challenge he has I would say that
cyclically are people going to want
another four years of Joe Biden given
how old he already seems um and dodgery
has to be unkind for a moment but he is
daughtery he's 80 he'll be 82 at the
election 86 at the end of his next term
if he runs again I don't think people
will vote for that over someone like
Trump who's never had a drink in his
life never had a cigarette never had a
drug so for mid 70s he's unbelievably
full of energy crazy compared to Biden
so I think he would beat Biden actually
this time